[Music]
well but I think the average person who
knows maybe a little bit about
psychology or a little bit about
Buddhism would think that the Buddhist
emphasis on or the Buddhist conversation
about the ego is all about getting rid
of the ego completely there's this
notion and Buddhist psychology of
egolessness or no self and most people
misinterpret that as Freud actually did
most people misinterpret it to think
that oh Buddhism is saying we don't need
the ego at all or we don't need the self
at all like get rid of it and then we're
one with everything and that's it
and I think that's wrong obviously we
need our egos a good friend of mine
Robert Thurman who's a professor of
Buddhism at Columbia professor of
religion at Columbia he had a Mongolian
teacher in the 1960s who used to say to
him about this topic of egolessness or
selflessness it's not that you're not
real of course you're real you know you
have a self but people like you secular
people who don't really understand think
that they're really real and what
Buddhism is teaching is that that that
belief in your own really realness is
misguided we take ourselves more
seriously than we need to
the the self is not as fixed as we would
like to think the the ego the ego is
born out of fear and isolation you know
it comes into being when a when
self-consciousness first starts to come
when you're 2 or 3 years old you know
and you start to realize oh I'm not
there's a person in here and you're kind
of like trying to make sense of of
everything who you are who are those
parents they're you know the ego is a
way of organizing oneself and it comes
from the intellect as the mind starts to
click in and for many people it stays in
a kind of immature place where our
thinking mind our intellect is defining
for our
who we are either taking all the
negative feedback like I'm not good
enough
and the ego fastens on to all the
negativity or the positive the
affirmation like oh I'm really something
you know and the ego likes certainty at
like security
it likes repetition and so it's always
reinforcing its own vision of itself and
that starts to restrict it starts to
restrict us to confine us to make us
think that word that we know ourselves
better than we actually do
so the to bring Buddhism in to therapy
or to bring Buddhism to a secular
audience it's all about starting to
doubt the ego a little bit maybe you
don't know yourself as much as you think
you do maybe some of those fixed ideas
that have been operating inside of you
since you were a little kid you know and
and conditioning the way you interact
with other people with the world maybe
those are not also right maybe you're
not as really real as you think you are
and you could start to let go of some of
that a little bit
[Music]